the initial ph and the equivalence point
are plotted on the graph below
accurately sketch the titration curve on
the graph below mark the position of the
half equivalence point on the curve with
an x
all right so we have they show they show
us the initial ph right over here
and they also show us the equivalence
point
right over here instead of ph of we
actually saw that in the last problem
with the equivalence the equivalence
point or actually a couple of problems
ago the equivalence point was measured
the ph at the equivalence point was
measured to be 2.54
so that's why
this right over here is at 2.54 when
we've added about 29 point i forgot what
the number was it was in the it was in i
think the second part of this problem
they said when you added close to 30
milliliters of that hydrochloric acid of
that 1.25 molar hydrochloric acid
solution that is when we hit our
equivalence point and we see the ph
right over there and then the half
equivalence point well that's going to
be when we've added half this amount so
it's going to be a little bit less than
15
and we in the last problem we figured
out that that was going to be the ph of
4.77 so a ph of
4.77 is going to be something like
right over there they said mark that
with an x so half equivalence point
we've added half the titrant there and
we know the ph we figured that out in
the last part of the problem and now we
just need to
graph we need to sketch the titration
curve
so
let's see we keep we keep adding more
and more hydrochloric acid hydrochloric
acid it lowers
lowers the ph
we get to the half equivalence point and
then actually we're going to we're going
to start leveling off over here the
reason why you level off is because
you're going to have you're going to
have more and more of the conjugate the
conjugate acid there and so as you as
you as you react with the conjugate base
with more and more of the conjugate base
the equilibrium between the conjugate
base and the conjugate acid more of that
acid is going to go to conjugate base so
you're going to have a little bit of a
buffering going on but at some point you
have reacted
you have completely reacted with
everything and you've you hit your
equivalence point
you hit your equivalence point and then
and you become much more acidic
and it might look something
it might look something like that
let me see if i can do a little bit
a little bit better
a little bit better job so
it would look something and we're
obviously it's not going to be exactly
right it's important we go through these
three points
and it would look something
something like that so that's the
equivalence point half equivalence point
and then this is our initial ph